warum ist Sahra Wagenknecht beliebter
bei den Anhängern der AFD als bei denen
der Linken selbst in den eigenen Reihen
gilt sie als Blues kennen ich bin
wirklich stinksauer in flüchtende
Menschen sieht sie ein großes
Sicherheitsrisiko auch ihre Haltung zu
Russland im Ukraine Krieg ist nah an der
AFD sie fordert die Aufhebung der
Sanktionen und keine Waffenlieferungen
mehr auf ihrer Friedensdemo versammelt
sie Rechte und Querdenker hinter sich
zuletzt spekuliert Sahra Wagenknecht
sogar öffentlich eine eigene Partei zu
gründen ist sie jetzt richtig für die
Partei oder gefährlich einerseits gehört
sie laut ZDF Politbarometer aktuell nach
Meinung der Befragten zu den zehn
wichtigsten Politikern Deutschlands als
einzige der Linken in den Top Ten
andererseits wird sie in Sachen
Sympathie und Leistung sehr schlecht
bewertet besser als in den eigenen
Reihen schneidet sie übrigens bei
afd-anhängern ab was meint ihr denn